can't trust this statement.
I I'm not going to I'm not going to reexlain my stream. I lied
to you. You lied about what you said to me. That is literally
what happened. But I don't care what's in her heart. Okay. I
read it more maliciously before I talked to you and then you
told me how maybe she was just and I was like, "Okay, I could
see that." Wait, so you're admitting that you felt she was malicious,
which is what you just said. I felt like Well, hold on. Hold
on. Hold on. What are we doing today?
So, I go rules I go rules did a stream the other day talking
about straighter raid. Now, I she did uh she did analysis. Now,
for all of you who don't know, Destiny is a streamer who and
shared their nudes to people without asking. And when he found
out or when he got found out, Pixie was in these videos and while
she was recognized in them, Pixie
still didn't want to go public.
she wanted to she didn't want to write uh well she she was fumbling
with a lot of her thoughts which is understandable. One thing
you'll see throughout this is that she had a big uh priority
where she wanted to keep things private. And so instead of
her first priority being nuking Destiny in public because that's
what she would have done, right? She already roughly had her
um
whatever man, you know, Substack written. She didn't want her
parents to find out. She said she would kill herself if her parents
found out. That's how we know that's important to her.
She told everyone around her that she was planning to end her
life. Why? Because her parents were going to find out. And you
will see that Aiko doesn't think privacy is important to Pixie.
You'll see Io think that Pixie just, you know, she she was always
going to sue Destiny,
but this damn story talked her out of it. bad analysis. Bad bad
analysis.
Now I go did the stream where she goes through everything and
I took a couple notes while watching and towards the end I uh
or after she finished I hopped on a call with her. I confronted
her not on her total analysis but on a lot of the things she
said cuz I didn't watch the whole thing. I didn't want to make
any conclusion and
there were times so I laid out my arguments and she even moved
on a couple of her points so that you know credit to her she
wasn't like uh steadfast in her opinions she made some you know
conclusions
but there were times in that call
where because I was kind of 2xing through and took rough notes
on her quotes paraphrasing what she said I
went in and confronted her and I said hey you said x y and z
and she said, "No, I didn't. Really?
You didn't say." So, the thing I accused her of was you attributed
malice or bad intent to
straight away. No, I didn't. I didn't. I just said, you know,
hey, she just made bad decisions. That's what she said to me
on the call. Now, I took her word for this. I said, you know
what, fair. I don't have an exact quote. I'm not here to nail
you to the wall about it. Uh, you did make, you know, some concessions
about some points. And
so I left and I didn't I told her I'd go listen back to the original
stream. But I trusted her. I said, "Look, you know, I'm not here
to, you know, I I I don't care enough to like,
you know, go back and listen again. I'm not going to like, you
know, hey, you made some concessions. I trust you. We'll call
it square." Well, me give an inch, they take a mile. And that's
what I did. So yesterday, last night, whatever, 1:00 in the morning,
I go hopped on just school stream and she's making I don't I
don't recall all her points. I won't say that she made, you know,
whatever uh contradiction statements. I don't I don't remember
a lot of it. It's I didn't sleep a lot in the last two days with
the cherry stuff and just not knowing if just was going to stream.
It was it was been a crazy couple days. So, forgive me if I'm
a little
fried. So anyway, so she hopped on and she's bringing up the
same points about Straighter Ed and that's fine, but it's clear
that, you know, she she felt the same way. So I said, "Oh,
okay. Well, I better listen back to that original stream then
if she's going to be if it wasn't just a one and done,
she's going to carry on this narrative that she feels strongly
about, why don't I do my due diligence?" And I did. And boy,
was I mistaken to trust her. I go lied. I go lied to me. Now,
a lot of people, including myself, like to say, "Well, straighterated
a stoner."
Look, I smoked weed for like a decade. I get it. My memory isn't
the best. I'm not going to say that you're,
you know, malicious if you don't remember something from 30 seconds
ago, which you often doesn't. But you're in commentary,
you're making strong statements about somebody's character, and
then when you're confronted, you lie about what you said. when
you made strong statements
conveniently when you're confronted
and you you know look she's there's nothing wrong with being
a little especially in an argument but if you are with I didn't
say that okay when I find out that you're lying I'm not going
to give you the charity of I'm just a stoner you lied you're
a lying sack of [__] does that make her always a
liar no but she lied in that instance and I didn't appreciate
that so we're here to outline why I was a lying sack of [__]
It doesn't mean I hate Ako, you know, whatever. I I don't have
a lot of, you know, feelings about one way or the other. You
know, she lets me come on and yell at her, and that's good enough
for me. Um, and she may even review this stream, which is also
fine. And I think that carries with it integrity. So, she may
have integrity and realized that maybe it was maybe I'll even
be charitable. Maybe she has more confidence in her memory than
she thinks. So, when she was saying to me what she truly thought
was her memory, but it's not, this doesn't mean she's being malicious.
Fair enough.
But if you're always seemingly forgetting the things that get
you out of trouble, there starts to be a pattern, isn't there?
That's what I'm starting to pick up. But look, I'm not here to
like destroy her, but she's a lion sack of in this instance.
So, let's get started. So, what I'm going to do, I uh thought
a lot about how I wanted to do this. I was going to
Um, what was I going to do? I was going to go through. So, because
she's um the the outline of her stream is basically that, you
know, Pixie and Straighter are friends. Pixie, you know, thinking
what she wants to do in this, you know, situation with Destiny.
And as she's considering things, she has friends and enemies
around her trying to talk in her ear. One of those people enemies
or people who are looking to hurt her is Kylo. One of those people
looking to help her is her best friend, Straight Rage. But Aiko
disagrees with that. Ieko thinks straight raid is just straight
ragde Maxwell. She is just another Kylo. Now it seems she kind
of goes back and forth on this that she is straight Kh straight
Maxwell but also she just made bad choices which kind of contradicts
itself. It's either she is kind of making these bad choices with
uh
you could say you know reckless disregard and and maybe some
bad choices. But then there are times where she says she's the
string puller where she is intentional
looking to play both sides and you know it doesn't mean that
there's a motive to but she clearly she has no regard for Pixie's
wishes and that's just not true. So
that said
I thought about how I wanted to if I wanted to pull all the screenshots
and do all the research.
No.
And why not?
one because my preconceived
um rationale helps me also be lazy. So, I like that. But mainly
because I'm not here to judge the facts.
Well, I am. But I'm not here to present new facts to disprove
Aiko. I am here to take all of Aiko's evidence and show her why
she's
with the facts she had in front of her. So, I'm not going to
bring in new evidence rough. You know, there may be a time or
two, but largely I'm going to condemn her for seeing a blue sky
and calling it red. That's what this stream is going to be. So,
let's get started. So, Aiko does a stream. I couldn't find like
an exact starting point. It kind of um fades in and out. Um I
think she had some tech issues, so it's not like she was whatever.
But so,
tomorrow night share my screen here. What we're going to do is
probably at like 1.5x or whatever, we're going to go through
some of the things she said in this stream and I'm going to probably
pull up some of the things she said in my next in the the later
part of the stream where she um claims that we uh you know makes
makes different claims and then I'm just going to analyze why
she's wrong. Um I'm not going to do this a lot during the stream.
Uh I'll pause this one time and maybe one time in the future
halfway through or something for questions. Um, does anyone have
any questions before we get started? If anyone, you know, thinks
they can't hear me or something because my I know I'm on a laptop,
but um, anyone have any questions? Um,
let's see here. Can everyone hear me? Okay, that's what I want
to hear in chat right now. Okay, no questions, but can everyone
hear a [__] Um, let's see. Let me share my screen
here. Uh, you trying to talk in her ear. One of those people
enemies or people who are looking to hurt her is Kylo.
One of those people looking to help her is her best friend straight
rap. But
uh let's see. Is it a little quiet? I don't even think it's quiet.
I think it's fine. Um is it clear? No. I'm going to mic. So you
guys um
let me see here. Check my my compressor here and then we'll get
started. I'm not going to with this forever. I can always clean
it up and post or whatever. And I can't like yell because I'm
in a apartment with other people. So, sorry guys. Um, check.
One, two. Check. Check. Uh, let's see here. Check. Chat. Any
questions? Okay. I'm not going to bicker with you, Aiko, from
your bed. This is what you can do. You're a big girl. You can
call in and state your problems.
Um, but I'm not going to snipe with you in chat. What I said
in this stream, I'm not going to present new evidence. I'm going
to take the evidence you already presented and show you why you're
wrong. If you have a problem with that, I don't know, take it
up with some take it up with me after. Otherwise, you can call
in. And uh in fact, let me make sure. So, you can call me. I'll
have my Discord up just for you um on the side. But if you have
a problem with something I say, give me a ring. I'm going to
be focusing on the stream. So, let's dive in, guys. All right.
So, here we are. So, I here
just starting our stream and the context we have here. She's
kind of We're going to start kind of mid her reading through
some analysis here from a couple people or sorry, some text messages
and let's dive in. Gotcha. I'm not an Let me Let me just remind
actually, you know what? Let's Let's just do this because um
I think it's a good reminder of how much Kyla sucks. Not that
we need a reminder to know that, but you know, how it was her
that suggested it the money in the first place. No, no, Dan was
not. There we go. What about the night after? Pixie wants to
go public before the end of January and I don't know what to
tell her because there's pros and cons both ways. Sunday says,
"Let's talk tomorrow. I'm going to talk with someone I trust."
Let's go back further. This is important money thing. And his
immediate reaction
um shares a a tweet about fairy queen um queen covering when
uh when fairy queen uh confronted about her support of destiny
and um Kyla said, "You're not a feminist. You're just you see
me as an extension of Steven. You're not a feminist." And then
blocked her. this. I don't need to read these, but these are
the DMs. Yeah. Gotcha. I'm not an Let me Let me just remind actually,
you know what? Let's Let's just do this because um I think it's
a good reminder. Come on. I didn't mean as little attention.
I really This is We need to be where she starting the There we
go. Now, this this uh is when I I highlighted a couple things
because I wanted to note them. Okay. So, at this point, this
being January 1st, we will go back to it
when we get to the Shreder Aid and Destiny DMs, but I would like
you to know that at this point, this is January 1st, she had
talked Sorry, I have my ringer off. What's up? Hey, so wait,
you have new you have new evidence that I haven't seen.
No.
No, because people in chat were saying that. No. What were you
saying then?
I said I'm not going to present new evidence. I said I was going
to like go over let's say the preponderance of evidence like
all let's say all of the DMs cuz I don't you know I think you
agreed you didn't probably go over all of them or you know maybe
there looked at all of them. No, I looked at everything that
was publicly available. Everything
you have other evidence. No, I did say that I did. I said that
I looked through everything. That's what I do. Riyle, I will
spend a billion hours looking at everything.
Um, regardless of what you think my analysis is of it, but Okay.
So, you haven't seen anything that hasn't been publicly available.
That's not a question I can answer. Okay. Well, then uh anything
in relation to what we're talking about right now? I don't know
why you're asking about what I know behind the scenes. That's
weird. No, no. I'm saying that I'm not going to use any of that
to prove what you're criticizing, right? But what you're criticizing
me, are you coming from a place that's more well-informed than
I am? No. I'm No. Nothing I say in the stream. You will be able
to you will be able to respond. I mean your personal opinion.
No. Do you know my No, you're interrupting me. But your interruption
doesn't change what I was going to say.
Nothing none of the when you watch this back or when you're watching
it now, nothing I say, none of my kind of none of my conclusions,
I will lay them out clearly. You know, if A then B and it will
all be from things on your screen. Nothing from outside. Okay.
And this is you're not affected by your opinion is not affected
by stuff that I don't have access to. If you asked me one more
time whether I'm biased or No, no, I'm not I'm not asking. You
asked it last night. Could you blame chat? No. You asked last
night if I was friends with Aaron while I was making point like
at the end of my argument where I laid down a very clear argument.
No, no, that's not what I'm talking about talking to Aaron. I'm
not talking about what you're implying. what you're implying
you don't maybe you don't know
you know whatever I'm not saying you're friends with Aaron what
the reason
you've seen evidence through someone I'm not talking about what
you're saying makes you think I'm not talking about what you're
saying I'm talking about what you're implying because I presented
very clear arguments that when you hear them made you change
your mind in our first call so you should know that I'm coming
to these through conclusions that I can repeat and make you understand
and get you to agree with so when you bring up at the end of
two days of us arguing at the second day of us arguing at the
end of that you ask hey you know is any of this are you friends
with Aaron is any of that affecting your read it was the chat
question well but you read the chat and you go oh that's a good
question to ask which but in the question it implies that I have
a bias when you I made you you know and now you're bringing up
a second time the chat I'm just letting you know it was people
in chat people were chat was saying that there was new evidence
that you had that you weren't going to leak
and like I said what chat
Okay. All right. All right. Um um then carry on. Bye. Fair enough.
And feel free to call again. Bye. All right. Thanks, guys, for
your patience
to Destiny and uh and told him. We will go back to it when we
get to the Shraider and Destiny DMs, but I would like you to
know that at this point, this is January 1st, she had talked
to Destiny and uh and told him that he should give Pixie money
December 12th. So, it's been more than a couple of weeks since
that happened. So, I think it's interesting how how Straighter
Aid frames this to Sunday, the the giving Pixie money thing.
And his immediate reaction, okay, Sunday said, "Saw, we'll go
over it tomorrow." And I was sniping it. I go, she did call in.
So, you know what? She's she's happy to and she always takes
my call. So, I was sniping at her for from chat because she said
she was busy today. She hopped on and I always respect that.
I just want to say, you know, I may say some strong condemnations
in this call. I always respect. She's willing to take my call.
She's willing to fight things out even if I'm oppressive. So
I I think I does have a lot of integrity and that's why I'm doing
this because I think that she's not she's not an awful person.
I think you just think she makes some really dumb conclusions
and those are going to be I think harmful
uh for a couple reasons, but I'll
Aaron says, "Nice. Kyla's being snaky about this. Pixie contacted
her and was kind of trying to use her as a liazison. I told her
Kyla can't be trusted to help with that, which is, you know,
true. We all know that's true. Dan contacted Pixie a couple weeks
ago as well. According to what she told me, he basically said,
"Asked Steven for a reasonable amount of money and he probably
pay it and wanted her to convince him to not take legal action
against Kiwi Farms, which he's considering."
So, I think it's interesting the way she framed this because
it sounds like he like Dan suggest suggested it suggested it.
Okay. Uh, Sunday says, "Are you up for a call later tonight?"
Aaron says, "Lyan and I are driving back from Texas. Won't be
home until late tomorrow night. What about the night after?"
Pixie wants to go public before the end of January, and I don't
know what to tell her because there's pros and cons both ways.
Sunday says, "Let's talk tomorrow. I'm going to talk with someone
I trust." Uh, Aaron says, "Sounds good." Sunday responds to this
highlighted message um about, you know, telling Pixie to Dan
telling Pixie to ask Steven for a quote unquote reasonable amount
of money. Uh, Sunday says, "This is blackmail. Tell her under
no circumstances to do this. Dan is a [__] or he's
trying to sabotage her." Okay. So, does Aaron say anything about
how it was her that suggested it the money in the first place?
No. No. Dan was not the first to talk about money.
That's Hold on to that. Um, okay.
These were messages Kyla and Pixie exchanged on uh December 18th.
Let me actually note that too. When Kyla and Pixie
Okay, so reminder for later. This is like almost a week when
when Kyla and Pixie talked. It's almost a week after Aaron first
discussed the financial stuff with Destiny. Okay, so this is
important just to make sure everyone's following. So Trade Raid
is in DMs with Pixie. She's showing on screen DMs with um you
know straight raid and president Sunday. Uh those two were friends
at the time and she is straighter is confiding in her friend
President Sunday. Now one thing that is very important for this
that Io misses she
concludes at the end of this or or throughout this that straight
raid was doing a very bad thing by confiding in Sunday. The issue
I take with this is it is very easy
to say, "Oh,
well, she just shouldn't have done that and therefore, you know,
she wasn't looking out for Pixie." The issue with that is you
have a friend and Straight Aid has always trusted Sunday. They've
been friends for years and he's never like backstabbed her even
though she's always been friends with Destiny and always been
in and around the Destiny community and he's never done. There
is a I think everyone who a lot of people who know Sunday wouldn't
have trusted him to not do that but at the same time the idea
that you
basically you have a friend
why is the friend going to commit
because they don't want their parents to find out about the leaks.
Now, I don't recall if Pixie lives alone, but I know she's very
uh close with her parents, was around her parents, and even lived
with her for long periods lived with them for long periods of
time. I don't know if she's back there, but the idea
I straight I'm sorry, Aika will condemn Straight Aid. You don't
know how to handle this. You shouldn't have stepped in. Pixie
wanted this private straight is in a tough position of trying
to balance her privacy.
You know, if you call services,
her parents are going to find out if she's been
locked up in a mental institution, you know, like uh you know,
the services aren't exactly great for that. So, she's confiding
in a friend. The idea that this was even a bad decision is questionable
at best.
She was friends with President Sunday and didn't think he would
backstab her. She was friends with Destiny. I'm guessing she
was friends with Destiny for that long. She thought there was
a hack. The narrative was the at the time was there was a hacker,
not that Destiny is this overtly evil, you know, person. Now,
you you can say that, hey, it was bad analysis that Destiny's
a good guy. Fine. But we have to assume that she's in the cult
of DGG. She's mind at the time. So, she's mind read by Destiny
and Destiny and they haven't gone public with the narrative.
you you know Pixie is very you know like uh quiet about this
or very just probably not giving a ton of details because she
doesn't want to get into the explicit nature of all this.
So a lot of this is straight trying to get a little bit of information
do some of her own analysis
and then try to talk to the people around her to get the most
help for Pixie as possible.
Somehow this is going to be turned as some bad decision. Now,
in retrospect, we can all say it wasn't a bad decision, but the
narrative Destiny was pushing was this was a hack.
Well, if Destiny was hacked, and if he can push the narrative,
and you don't think he's evil just yet, well, then he's really
not a bad person to talk to because he was hacked. Right now,
I think she knew at the time that
whatever she he had shared this one thing unconsensually,
right? the I don't think the narrative yet was understood at
least by these people that he was this insane person where he
was sharing thousands of people's or thousands dozens of people's
news right so if you contextualize that information it is reasonable
that if she thinks that Destiny was act and he's not evil and
if he even probably is pushing a narrative further than that
I don't have I'm not going to I'm not going to dig through the
original Walt I'm here to show a different narrative
where
I go come to conclusions based on what she has in front of and
why there are other narratives that are more
and the conclusions she's coming to are faulty. So, she has a
friend and she's trying to help that friend. Wow, you shouldn't
help somebody who you have no business. What's your bit? What
the Iiko will say that straight red has no
trying to help her and then at the same time she needs to follow
Pixie's wishes and at the same time she's not giving Pixie autonomy.
But she doesn't have all the DMs between Straid and Pixie. I
believe we don't have all those DMs. There are DMs in there where
it's clear that Pixie has wishes and Stra is trying to follow
those.
But then you say don't help. Well, okay. Well, if you can't go
get services cuz that would make things public and she has no
business helping. You're saying she shouldn't talk to other people
to get help cuz that's what she's doing that you're telling her
not to do. That's the issue here. All right. So, let's continue.
So, okay. These were messages Kyla and Pixie exchanged on 128.
This is from Aaron saying this. Kylo was telling Pixie that she
would talk to Stephen Ireel about the whole ordeal, but then
said scheduling issues prevented the conversation. She also says
every time she tried to ask for details via messages, he's not
engaged. But I think that's a lie, obviously. And for context,
Pixie wanted to sue for a lot of money, literally a million dollars,
but I told her that amount isn't realistic. And then she sends
the the scrolling video to to Sunday, the one that this is the
Kyla DMs.
Kyla and Fixiey's DMs. So, not straight, right? Everyone ended
up having um screenshots at the very least from Okay, these are
why uh Sunday ultimately made that video because Nicholas Dioro
came to him with screenshots from this and Sunday realized that
Aaron had been yapping all over the place. Okay, straight. Let
me just look here. See if there's anything I missed. Okay. and
she's discouraged from pursuing a Leoo after speaking with a
lawyer who specializes in cyber crime/ revenge and they told
her that the hacker is at more fault legally than Steven which
I think is ridicul
so so we have two pieces of evidence here at least we have straight
raid believes the narrative about the hacker, which it still
might have been, but she clearly is using hacker to show that
there's not a lot of maliciousness on Destiny, at least in this
whole situation or at least in this portion of the situation.
So, we can probably assume that piece of straight raids mental
image. Two,
Pixie talked to an attorney. So, she talked to an attorney who
specialized
in cyber crimes and revenge and they told her it probably wasn't
going to work out in court. So, the logical conclusion for that
is if you go with a lawsuit, you're
not going to get anything out of this. Now, is it right to to
conclude that getting something out of this is the way to go
and not punishing Destiny? I don't know. We'll find out more.
But the issue with this is that she's about to condemn. Well,
we'll hear her out before I give my conclusions. Revengeorn and
they told her that the hacker is at more fault legally than Stephen.
Um, which I think is ridiculous because again, there was never
there is no hacker. There was never evidence of a hacker. That's
just the thing Destiny said. Okay.
And it is ridiculous because we know now. Yes. 6 months in the
future, you have the best hindsight glasses ever. Come on, you
piece of [__] Oh my god, my computer isn't loading.
Don't do this. I don't even know if I'm streaming still. What
the guys? Oh, I'm just I guess I need to uphold music. What the
is All right, let's try this. Let's reload it. Come on. Okay,
which is why she wants to go public about it. She feels like
there's not going to be any legal justice and doesn't want him
to get away with it. Um, also, okay, Sunday says Dan is a [__]
U, we read that earlier. Aaron responds to that saying, "Also,
Steven wasn't aware that Dan was contacting Pixie from what she
could tell." Additional context. Pixie was saying that if her
parents found out, she would kill herself. Sunday says
Pixie says if her parents found out, she would kill herself.
So, I don't believe this is a news story yet. Hasn't hit like
the Daily W uh mail or what you know, whatever the news articles
that came out. So, she doesn't want the if we can take a reasonable
guess about what Pixie's biggest priorities are and she says
her parents if they find out I'm going to end my life, we can
probably reasonably assume her privacy is
It sounds like potentially even more important than um making
Destiny pay
at least you know publicly. She sounds like her number one if
if the thing that is going to take her from the face of the earth
is her parents finding out going to court is probably going to
involve her parents being in the newspaper or the you know the
online newspaper is probably going to get back to her parents
especially since they know destiny. So when straighter aid if
we can imagine her mental model of what is the future potentials
here and how can I prioritize my friend Pixie's wishes she's
going to say a lot of things that contradict Pixie is in a state
we can say that she has a lot going on she is stressed she is
scatterbrained so because of this
straight has to sort through all of Pixie's thoughts
what can I take from Pixie's thoughts to understand what her
priorities are oh she's that she was going to kill herself if
her parents found out. Sounds like she values her privacy, at
least her not her parents finding out, not making this international
news. I think that's a reasonable conclusion.
So, when Straighter Aid is advocating for Pixie to get money
behind the scenes, and it sounds like from all attorneys that
Destiny
wouldn't pay for what he did.
Okay, there's another thing. If an attorney looked at all the
evidence that Destiny wasn't probably going to pay for what he
did, it probably is reasonable to assume that Pixie and Straight
A didn't at least have a lot of evidence that he was a super
malicious actor and doing reckless things. Yes, maybe this one
instance, but they didn't even have enough evidence to show that
Pixie was disharmed by things
that the hacker was more at fault. It is probably also reasonable
to assume that they didn't have they they maybe have understood
him as a bad guy, but they, you know, her talking to Destiny,
she doesn't see him as the devil she sees him as today likely.
And I think that's important to remember. Yes, she may have been
clouded. She knows this person for many years, both of them.
the idea that excuse me that straight raid would talk to Destiny.
Obviously in retrospect stupid
but if she even in one iota feels that maybe he was a victim
in this as well meaning it is a mutual situation or the facts
are unknown. Remember all this evidence wasn't public. Pixie
didn't tell her story. Now she probably told a little bit the
straight raid but Pixie doesn't I'm guessing Pixie doesn't just
like to just vomit information about what happened even to her
best friend. She's very reserved. She doesn't want this to go
public. She's embar that the number one thing to her is the fact
that all of this is public. That's why she felt violated by this
is that even one other person knowing her having her, you know,
video was that upsetting to her. I think it is a very easy through
line and it is almost redundant to say that Pixie cares about
this not going public or privacy and
President Sunday relatively, you know, it probably would have
gone out anyway, forced her hand to go public. Now, do we know
if she would have gone public anyway because she had a Substack
pre-written?
I just, you know, it's very reasonable, I think, to assume she
had a substack,
draft it, but then, you know, whatever. She's sitting there and
doesn't actually publish it or does, you know, it's it's a future
plan that she keeps putting off because she doesn't truly
want to go public. These are all, you know, I just I think these
are all relatively easy conclusions that are within the realm
of possibility
and it shows that straight raid here is trying to work out for
Pixie's best interest
and that's all her to keep cool. She's going to be all right.
Sunday says, "Assume everyone knows everything." Trade says,
"Uh, I did. She's calmed down since then and hasn't repeated
anything related just since. What do you think of Kyla's messages
to her? I know Pixie is delusional to think she could get that
sort of money, but I thought Kyla's tone was off when addressing
monetary compensation. She made it sound like Pixie was wrong
to even expect money.
Oh, I don't have really really an ad. I paid for premium. Oh,
but I have to do this on Firefox. Okay, state school ad poison
people's ability to fund raise for stuff like that. Sorry, guys.
Um,
okay, these are why uh Sunday ultimately made that video because
Nicholas Dioro came to him with screenshots from this and Sunday
realized that Aaron had been yapping all over the place. Okay.
trader aid said and she's discouraged from pursuing a leeroo
after speaking with a lawyer who specializes in cyber crime/revention
and they told her that the hacker is at more fault legally than
Steven which I think is ridicul because again there was never
contacting from what she could tell additional context was saying
that if her parents found out she would herself Sunday says tell
her to keep cool she's going to be all right Sunday says assume
everyone knows
says uh I did she's calmed down since then and hasn't repeated
anything related just since what do you think of Kyla's messages
to her I know Pixie is delusional to think she could get that
sort of money but I thought Kyla's tone was off when addressing
monetary compensation she made it sound Pixie was wrong to even
expect money.
So here, Straighter is saying, let's hear that one more time.
The last line anything related is just sense. What do you think
of Kyla's messages to her? I know Pixie is delusional to think
she could get that sort of money, but I thought Kyla's tone was
off. So here Strader is saying that Ka's tone is off to say money
shouldn't be, you know, uh, sought after. So Straer is saying
that Pixie deserves money. She's also saying that Pixie is delusional
to think she could get that sort of money because she already
talked to a lawyer and the lawyer said Destiny was probably not
going to be like, you know, held accountable. So, you know, that's
that's the conclusion we can come from there. When addressing
monetary compensation, she made it sound like he was wrong to
even expect money.
Awesome. Forgot how spurgey Sunday came off here. TF is that
guy slash. Thank you so much, Missa, for the $5. I will add that
to the numbies go in the singing about her mombo here. Um, something
that really bothered me. So yeah, saying she's delusional to
think she could get that kind of money. Um, Pixie wanted that.
She was basically trying to use Kyla as a liaison.
Dumb. Sunday says Pixie is really dumb. You and I have to assume
that if we deal with her straightly, she will make a very stupid
decision. Aaron says probably, but even if I convince her to
not go down the route she's currently planning, I consider that
a win. Right now, she's thinking a tweet longer and a GoFundMe
for legal fees. While I do think some people hate Stephen enough
to open their wallet and donate to what could be a legal headache,
I don't think it's a good idea because of how pixie is. No one
can lose sympathy faster than her and couples poison people's
ability to fund raise for stuff like that. So this made me stop
and think what do you mean pixie no one can lose sympathy
faster than Pixie. What does that mean? Like that's like some
basically reading some of these messages I feel like there's
like a like an annoyance or a
This is Iiko's autism or whatever. I'm I'm not saying she's diseased
in the brain. I'm saying she's
she is perceiving something that isn't there. So straighter is
a very
very direct person. She will tell you what she's thinking at
any time roughly. So and she's going to be direct about it. She's
not going to sugarcoat it. The idea that Pixie loses sympathy
is just a
Now, we're going to hear a little bit more here, but I'll explain.
Trader has in regards to Pixie. Like I don't know like listen
living with someone is hard. Living working with a friend someone
who's already a friend and then you start living with them that
always creates friction. It's not a good idea typically to live
with your friends um that you've already been friends with or
friends quote unquote friends quote unquote. So um yeah. So that
no one can lose sympathy faster than her. I think that's crazy
especially since yeah Pixie is basically like the perfect victim.
So well yeah right and wrong. Pixie is the perfect victim.
Straighter aid is not talking about her victimhood. She's talking
about her public opinion, her ability to lose sympathy from the
public.
That is different than being a perfect victim. Yes, Pixie is
many ways the perfect victim. What she also is is a bit silly
sometimes. I mean, these are things that are just look, I'm I'm
an advocate for Pixie. Not let's just say I'm on her side. I'll
just say um not that I talk to her. I just I believe her all
that blah blah blah. When Strader is saying that she loses sympathy,
Pixie will go and fight with trolls on Twitter. She does not
handle optics very well. When you're talking about advocating
for your friend and helping her down a path that she wants to
go, you know, whatever to get her to a better place
and you are confiding in your friend President Sunday, you are
going to have to have tough conversations. Ieko thinks, "Oh,
you can never espouse your thoughts about other people in private
to somebody else where they're not. This is just this is this
is dumb. This is dumb."
Pixie walks into traps and trolls online. She just does. She
says herself. She wants nobody talking about all of this. She
basically wants it to never happen in the way that that where
like if everyone knew it but nobody would talk about it publicly
and it wouldn't spread further. I think that would be like her
ideal outcome. But she goes and searches her name online and
then she engages with those people and she engages in a let's
just say a bit of a silly way sometimes where she's fighting
with someone who's just trying to get under somebody's skin.
She's not like she's not she's not affecting the outcome she
wants, right? She thinks by combating the narrative and fighting
with a troll, she thinks that she can affect the outcome of informing
that person when they're just there to start. So, she has a goal
and she's going about it in a faulty way, right? That is a conversation
you're going to have to have. How do we prevent Pixie from hurting
herself
unintentionally?
And the idea that this is a bad thing. Well, I think what she's
saying, she's reading into this that um either straight raid
has a uh poor reason, you know, poor reasoning in this situation
about Pixie or about Pixie's actions and that straight raid has
a lack of sympathy and empathy for Pixie. And I think it is the
opposite. I think this uh 100% going with what Pixie says, I
think I believe in my
recollection and mental model, the way I heard this whole stream
a couple times now, IO does roughly make the conclusion that
Strider should go with Pixie's wishes 100%.
She should 100% follow Pixie's wishes. Now, she says in the call
with me that she didn't say that. I think the logical conclusion
of what she says is she's saying that follow straight raid should
be just going with what Pixie wants and never like not contradicting
that never look at you know what are the downstream effects of
that and is that what she really wants you have to she she wants
it to she wants straight away to assume that Pixie is a perfect
actor and she is not and then you know that the issue is when
I say this Aiko will contradict herself later and say well Pixie
scatterbrain and it's like well but That contradicts the point
that you should follow her exact what she says as her wishes
because she'll say something different at a different time which
I go is acting like Pixie. Oh. Um yeah, it sounds like Aaron
was losing sympathy for her. So the idea that uh straight is
losing sympathy. There's no evidence of this. She is actively
trying to help her friend. You're reading into this incorrectly.
Sunday says, "Is Pixie in Florida?" Sends a link to uh
Aaron says, "I sent this to her the same week they got leaked."
Sunday says, "Why is she talking to Kyla then?" Well, traitor
said that's how she found the lawyer through reading this in
some other resource because she started um
do I want to make this narrative? Iiko is in no way Io is in
a way her own little pixie. Do you know why? Well, no. Iiko is
in a way is her own little story raid. Straight raid is befriending
or is friends with at the time President Sunday. She's confiding
in President Sunday. President Sunday is going to use that for
his own ends. President Sunday has the narrative, right, that
the ultimate moral thing was to go public and he believes that.
I I mean, maybe he maybe he says otherwise, but from what I remember,
he can correct that. I'm not here to say I I I recall perfectly
his, but from what I recall, especially what he was arguing last
night with just was that he felt that was the moral thing to
do. Maybe I'm wrong, but the point is straight raid got used
for President Sunday's ends. his goals. I feel because I feel
President Sunday could have waited for Pixie to go public and
then made his story. He could have talked to Pixie about her
wishes. But instead he chose to go public without the even even
says I would be a you know what if I was a psycho? If I was a
psycho I would just go public cuz you know that would be risking
pixie and then he doesn't. So he knows the risks and he does
it anyway.
makes this narrative that straight raid is evil and guess who
comes on stream later? President Sunday. And now he starts condemning
straight raid as evil off of Ieko's faulty logic.
And then I believe Ieko is being used for President Sunday to
craft a narrative because straight raid is very quiet on this.
She does not talk about this.
I have my conclusions on that. But for better or worse, she does
not talk about this. And I think President Sunday knows that.
President Sunday knows that she's not going to contradict President
Sunday's narrative that Aaron that she's evil
and I think he's using that gray area. I don't know why, but
I believe to launder a bit of his image cuz that's what he seems
he's doing. He comes on stream to go, "Wow, Aaron is evil." But
this is a dumb conclusion that he's using and he knows that.
I think he's smarter than that to think that Straight's evil
off of this.
So that's my thoughts.
We'll see what responding to Sunday asking why she's talking
to Kyla
because she started to get impatient. And if I didn't say yeah
so I was getting used by President Sunday. That's the point.
She's just like straight was discouraged by what the two lawyers
she spoke to said Sunday says Jesus does the conversation continue
or did she send anything else? Trader between her and Kyla. Not
sure that was all she sent. Sunday says or with Steven. Okay.
Um and here this but this is when Destiny offered first offer
way or fixes everything for you. But if you have any bills or
owe money, we're not here. We're here for the analysis. So, I'm
going to try to get to the point here. That he give her money
for therapy and for law school. Okay. So, after um this is a
direct result of Aaron suggesting that he give her money for
therapy and for law school, but not an state school at best.
Okay, we'll see. So, here we have a problem.
She says
this is a direct result of stro suggesting to Steven, well, we
don't know that Pixie didn't suggest this to Straight Raid based
on the information in the stream.
Iiko has zero evidence
that shows that it was just straight raids idea. Pixie talked
about money and we don't have all the pixie and straight raid
DMs. It is well within the realm of possibility that Pixie said
at first.
So this idea that straight rage is responsible and she wasn't
just looking out for Pixie's wishes
is silly because Ieko has no evidence. She is using a lack of
evidence to say a conclusion. That's not how that works. That
later on. Okay. Uh January 1st continued. Yeah, there's no way
tonight. Wait, hold on. This is directly after those other ones.
Yeah, there's no way tonight. Yes, let me find them. That's from
Aaron. Um Sunday says okay. Then Aaron sends him DM the DMs between
Destiny and Pixie where she tells him that uh you know her ideation
stuff like that. And Destiny trying to give her don't give yourself
pep talk. And then Trader says she was threatening to kill herself
to him, but she told me this wasn't serious. It was just to get
his attention. And I would like to stop and say that a person
would say that. I don't know. I don't know. This is one thing
Aiko is going to do. Aiko is going to say many times during this
stream, "Oh, straight a shouldn't
what role just what gives right straight a right to talk about
a person?" I don't know. Her friends
Iiko doesn't cite credentials one time, but says, "Well, straight
doesn't know what she's doing. She doesn't she has no credentials."
But then I gives a contradicting narrative without citing any
credentials. This is just even if you're right, you're
because you have no credentials. You're saying not having credentials
or any knowledge of makes you ill-informed. And then you give
an opinion which what you just said is you just and you'll say
this. You'll say you'll give an opinion after saying giving opinion
without credentials or without you knowing anything about not
being a professional is stupid. And you give your opinion. It
just you're you're even if you're right, you're wrong. And it
just makes your head hurt thinking about it. Sorry.
The you're talking about like so in all of this, I got to say
I think it is insane that has the audacity to think that she
knows how to handle this uh friend. And there it is. She has
the audacity.
What gives you the you're you just said that she has the audacity
to help her friend who is
and now you're going to tell us your opinion about how to handle
a person when you just said it's ridiculous her ability to judge
where she's at if she's for real or not. That's not how you handle
it. Um okay, this is really bad. Let's listen to that again.
saying that Aaron has the audacity to think that she knows how
to handle this uh friend and her ability to judge where she's
at, if she's for real or not. That's not how you handle it. Um,
you never handle it by judging whether they're for real or not.
It is very important. In fact, Kyla, I'm guessing doesn't Kyla
is a I don't take almost any of her analysis seriously,
but I'm guessing dealing with addiction, you know, counseling,
she does and has at times dealt with this person
the first thing she does is ask about means to figure out if
she's serious or not. Because that's probably important if somebody
is trying to actually do it. If they have a rope around their
neck or if they just say they're every Wednesday because they
hate Wednesdays. That's probably important. You
involid. You're just this is dumb. This is stupid. And also this
this attitude of like when she said um let's see.
Yes. Okay. So this when she says probably but even if I convince
her to not go the route she's currently planning, I consider
that a win, which is a tweet longer and a gofund me for legal
fees. So, I don't know what gives Aaron the impression that she
has the judgment or it's any of her business or that it's her
place to say what is reasonable or not in Pixie's pursuit of
justice and it will get Okay. So, you're saying don't advocate
for your friend.
Don't try to help your friend was if Pixie is saying a lot of
things. I want my privacy but I want to get justice for this
but I want to get some, you know, but I, you know, want him to
pay for this and all these things, but I want to kill myself,
but my parent I don't want my parents to find out. There's a
lot of things she has to sift through because Pixie is not a
good advocate for herself. She is a very, just to be blunt, a
very impotent person. She's very malleable person. It's very
clear,
but it's so obvious. So, Aaron being the direct one of the friendship,
the more straight talking, yes, you're going to have to may have
some tough conversations, giving some analysis that if Pixie
heard, it might hurt her feelings. this does not make her bad
or this is she has the right to try to help her friend. The other
side is well just you know baker actor just call the you know
call the police station I should say so your friends because
you have no right what is this logic this is dumb this is dumb
this is dumb at worse later on when we look at Aaron and Destiny's
DMs okay then uh she sends DMs between the god I don't know why
it doesn't just play the ad. It doesn't even play the ad. Okay
the judgment or it's any of her business or that is her place
to say what is reasonable or not in Pixie's pursuit of justice
and it will get worse later on when we look at Aaron and Destiny's
DMs. Okay. Then uh she sends DMs between uh herself and Pixie.
I don't remember. I don't can't say what she said, but you know,
it's about the uh the case, I guess. I can't make this bigger.
It's fine. It's fine. Uh Sunday says it's not. You don't think
that's important, Echo? The DMs between Straight Arid and Pixie
about the case. You didn't grab a screenshot where you could
read it and now you are bypassing that because
you're going to make a lot of conclusions off of the conversation
between Pixie and Straight Raid, but you don't even want to read
the DMs. It's even worse than I thought. She has DMs and she
chose not to read them cuz I'm guessing I I'm I'm guessing they
are at proper resolution in the
in the video. Not I'll apologize, but I'm guessing those are
readable. I can almost read them at 480p here, but she she just
she didn't want to, but she's gonna make a conclusion off of
what's in there. Florida, it's federal Justice Department, Congress.
Aaron says, "Yeah, she knew she knew that at the time, which
is why she was frustrated with this lawyer because they specialize
in this, but didn't mention that." Okay, now. So, that was the
first. Now, we're skipping to a week later. January 8th, Trader
A DM Sunday. Update. She sent me a statement. She wants to publish,
but it's terrible. I think it's too long. Reveals irrelevant
personal info that works against her and has other basic. Give
me one second. I'm going to play some music for like 30 like
a minute. I just need to grab my phone. It's on the charger.
Bear with me. All right. Like I said, I could call me if she
takes any issue with anything said here. Um, and has a thought,
but let's keep going. Oh my god.
Play first. Now we're skipping to a week later. January 8th
straight a DM Sunday update. She sent me a statement she wants
to publish, but it's terrible. I think it's too long. Reveals
irrelevant personal info that works against her and has other
basic typos or medical errors that makes it a bit hard to follow.
How would you rework this to be a better statement? I've asked
her for a VC later where I can talk to her about this stuff.
Um, Sunday says I wouldn't let her publish this. Success here
doesn't equal poetry. I think this is fine. The details work
in her favor. However, she should record it. This should be a
video in my honest opinion. So
again, I will say the the management
the like sort of the planning that Aaron's doing that like doesn't
involve even like Pixie's understanding or autonomy in this.
The trying
wrong. She's talking to Pixie. It involves her understanding
and knowledge. Autonomy.
Pixie is impotent and doesn't use her own autonomy. When you
have a friend who's a little bit more impotent and you are the
straight or like straight talking one and you have a long friendship
where it may involve you helping them with personal matters,
you are going to typically the straight talking person is going
to be the one who advocates for that friend. more often than
not in these situations when she's just sitting there doing nothing
to help herself. Unfortunately, because she's not only a more
impotent or kind of shy person and she's reaching out to you
and confiding in you about this situation,
you will have to advocate for her. You will have to help your
friend.
She's not going to do it herself
and she doesn't want to. Otherwise, she would be doing it. Again,
I will say the the management the like sort of the planning that
Aaron is doing that like doesn't involve even like Pixie's understanding
or economy in this like trying to persuade uh Pixie into going
a certain direction just because it is okay to help
your friend sort out their
If we agree, which she will say later, that she is scatterrained
and she is saying things that contradict themselves.
talking to your friend and the people you are confiding around
you
about guiding her to what she wants most. If she's going to kill
herself if her parents find out and then she talks about doing
a live stream about it
you can probably assume and after you talk to her that what she
really wants is the privacy and destiny to pay for it. And that
may be money behind the scenes. And you can say that's stupid
or whatever because it's whatever it's her main. She's going
to kill herself if her parents find out. And going public involves
telling her parents because it will be in the papers. She will
be doing a lawsuit. Her parents are probably going to have to
She's going to Why you Why are you going to the courthouse every
week, Pixie? So, you're trying to sort your friend's thought
out thoughts out. And that involves guiding her a bit. Trying
or just like it's not even guiding like involves some sort of
I haven't seen any evidence that straight tries to control Pixie.
She is just trying to lay out the options in front of her and
make sure she has the most options that align with what she
So, this is just bad analysis.
Aaron thinks that is what is would make sense or be fair as we
will see later in the Destiny DMs. And then this is uh I'm not
going to read it because we've read it so many times, but you
can pause and read it if you would like to. This is uh the the
statement that Pixie put out, but this is the pre before the
edit when it still has Dan Salman in it. Dan Saltman. Nice. Okay.
Continued the same day. Um, Trader sends to Sunday. Uh, her her
pixie DMs. Trader responding, "Yes, or you can tell me on a call
whatever you prefer." Trader says, "What day were you thinking
about releasing it?" Pixie says, "I mean, the most I can think
of is the Virginia stuff or NAS, but I have trouble seeing how
you would do that in a way that doesn't make him look worse.
We're trying to deflect."
Um, and Pixie responds to what day were you thinking about releasing
it? Going to talk to my lawyer first and send a demand letter
and based on his response to said letter, release it. I originally
wanted to do it by next week, but seems unlikely. And Straighter
Aid responds to Sunday saying, "Soon as she tries to seem selfless,
Kyla can bring up her digging for money." Trader says, "Yeah,
agreed." Sunday says, "Encourage her to release it first." Which
is this is an interesting response. "Yeah, agreed to soon as
she tries to seem selfless." Notice how she doesn't have any
condemnation for President Sunday who's trying to guide and tell
Pixie what to do. Later in the stream,
Aiko said she wouldn't do a stream about President Sunday that
went over his bad actions or good actions, right? Well, good
action, but she's if there was something bad to come out, she
wouldn't do a stream unless he raped. It's very interesting.
So she has bias for her friends. She doesn't give her honest
opinion about her friends.
So I mean you can say a good friend would lie about their friend
and but you're a public commentator and so you're saying we can't
trust you. You're saying don't trust me. There's a big sign above
I says don't trust me if my friends are involved. Bring up her
digging for money. I don't know what she's agreeing with but
interesting. Um Sunday asked 2 days later on the 10th of January.
Update. Nope. I haven't heard from her since the 8th but she's
been active so she's just ignoring me. Sunday says, "We'll give
it a couple days." Uh, Aaron marks that with a 100% emote. Aaron
says, "I'd like for her to update me, and she kind of randomly
had been through this whole thing, but I think she's annoyed
with me." Sunday says, "I think if she continues to evade you,
we need to assume she's been paid off." I would like to say this,
too. Sunday, um, and I've said this before, I said this to Sunday.
Um, he actually That's right. I forgot about this. She So, she
does, we'll let her say it, but his presumption that Pixie had
been paid off already, and he said that in the video. I think
that is very, uh, I think that was a very unwarranted assumption
that she'd have settled like so quickly. But, um, yeah, I don't
think that was reasonable, but that's fine. So I will say so
she at least she will contradict her friends. I don't think she's
going to condemn them. That's I think my original read is right.
She's not going to condemn her friends for their actions. Uh
you know unless there's a default which I you know cool I guess.
Um okay. Um Trader says I told her gently to readjust her expectations
with money that she could receive in any sort of settlement and
said the demand letter first wasn't a good idea. Uh and she says
nah she would tell me if she settled.
Sunday says she's evading you. You sure? Karen says yeah. There's
no way she wouldn't tell me. Sunday says, "This is not an honest
person. Her first impulse was to try and blackmail Steven with
her." We'll continue to be gentle. In fact, if dissuading her
from the demand letter seems to put up barriers, I'd choose a
different tactic. Go along with it and try to adjust what she
says. I'd ask her, "Hey, do you want to go over your demand letter?"
And then keep a record of everything. So, I'm I'm going to I'm
sure right now she's going to say, "What right does President
have? What does he know about? Why is I'm Michael and I only
condemn other people that aren't my friends? But I'm going to
condemn for being evil in this situation for even trying to nudge
Pixie in one direction, but I'm not going to comment when President
Sunday does it. I think it's interesting that even still here,
Aaron does not correct Sunday's Oh, we're going to attack Sunday
or sorry, we're going to attack straight raid. We're not going
to attack Sunday in that statement trying to tell her what the
victim to do. We're going to attack straight raid. Why is she
going to attack her? We'll find out. I think it's interesting
that even still here, Aaron does not correct Sunday's uh assumptions
about Pixie and how the money thing came to be. Cuz remember,
this is January 10th. It's almost it's like almost a month after
Aaron was the one who suggested giving Pixie money to Destiny.
She could have clarified this for Sunday and uh maybe maybe he
wouldn't have held that against Pixie. This is amazing.
Let's hear more of this. So, she does not in here talk about
how Sunday went public with
uh we'll just say, you know, I think it was relatively a good
thing that he went public with it. I'll say that outright. I
think it was probably a good thing. I haven't fully flushed out
that thought. I think it was good. But what's interesting here
that Sunday was the one who had the blackmail narrative and she's
going to blame Straight Array for not correcting him for him
having that conclusion.
And she I think she goes further to say that you know it's it's
even more straight raid's fault. But when it's interesting the
DMs here between straight raid and president Sunday straight
raid is giving like five to seven word answers. It doesn't look
like she's g giga engaged here. How much time is between? Okay,
these are quick DMs
He's laying out a long message here. And if Straight Ray doesn't
correct President Sunday on every falsehood he says or everything
when she's maybe she's just trying to get information or like
his thoughts. She doesn't have to correct him. That's not her
job.
That's his conclusion he's making and he can have that thought.
Maybe he wouldn't have held that against Pixie.
Oh, Trade Raid. Trader 8 says, "I don't have a time stamp because
he's still live, but loner box said on his stream this morning
that he's taking a break from streaming for a while. Alluded
to what happened." Sunday said, "What did he say?" Aaron says
that he wants to reevaluate what direction he takes his content
in and a lot of personal drama that he can't discuss that has
been going on in the background. Sunday says, "Lol, and this
is from Benz or from this is Hassan talking about it." Um, okay.
Sunday says, "Let me know when you're available." Okay, this
is the 16th now. Okay. So, she DM'd him on the 16th about Loner
Box. Okay. And this is where it's going to get crazy. This is
where it's going to get crazy. Okay. I have to pee. I have to
pee. So, I'm going to give you smacking. Oh, awesome. We love
it.
Oh my god, I love it. Let me know when you're available to talk.
This is a good time to condemn.
Uh, you know what? We'll wait for this. Ferious development.
Good development. Trader says, "Oo, I'm not free to talk until
tomorrow night to chat. TLDDR, or should it wait?" Sunday says,
"Urren, actually." Trader says, "Tell me." I can't pass anything
to Pixie, though. She's not replying and I just don't feel comfortable
bringing anything up about this to her. Okay, so here, these
are redacted, but we know who these are, right? Sunday says,
"I just talked to redacted Nicholaso." He has the Pixie erite
messages and he leaked them to me. He has them and shared them
to me. Did you share with anybody else? Trader says with I imagine
Chad Logic. Was it the exact same video? I know. Redacted. Kyla
wouldn't have shared it cuz remember those screen recordings
were sent that screen recording between Kyla and Pixie taking
my pixie sent to Shrader as her friend and then Shrader Raid
sent it to Sunday Chud and honestly who knows who else. Yeah.
Who who knows who else? Even though she's kind of trying to like
figure out, you know, how to help her friend best, right? You
know, that's seems to be we don't have any reason to believe
otherwise. There is nothing here that will show that she is looking
for anyone but looking out for anybody but Pixie. And she is
trying to cons confide in the people around her to get help.
But we're supposed to say she's supposed to do she doesn't isn't
allowed to help, but she isn't allowed to call public services
cuz that's going to involve probably her parents getting her
out of the mental institution. So, you're just gonna say don't
help your friend whatsoever.
This is good. This is good. Sunday says don't know. He said in
my combo that he didn't have a scrolling video, but I never mentioned
it was scrolling. Trader says hm. Sunday said, "And he's got
all of it." So, he definitely has it. What did you send to whom
specifically? Trader said, "I sent the video. I never took screenshots
to I assume this reduction is ch logic." Okay, next thing. Cuz
remember all these screenshots, these are just what is has been
made publicly available um that were in Becket's video, Sunday's
video. And then when we get to Aaron and Destiny, it'll be from
Destiny's manifesto. Okay. Sunday says, "Can I ask you a blunt
question?" Aaron says, "Yes, of course." Sunday says, "Have you
talked to Steven directly throughout any of this?" Aaron says,
"Yes." Sunday asks, "What was said between you two?" Trader said,
"He told me about Pixie." And I said he should offer her compensation.
They talked from there, but Pixie told me the combo broke down.
So, this is the first time uh January 16th. Okay. January 16th
is the first time that she actually tells Sunday
about having uh been the one to suggest the money thing. Okay.
offering compensation to Pixie isn't making the decision for
her. So, you leave her
and it gives her another option for how she could handle the
situation where Destiny pays, but things stay a little bit more
quiet. I I mean, I can't imagine
how you would say that this is bad, that Pixie has another option,
that she has to go with the lawsuit
um over a month after she first uh suggested it to Destiny. Okay.
Um, let's see. There's a screenshot of the time stamp. Okay.
Okay. This one. Trader responds to Sunday who said, "But given
that your impulse is to try and find a mole, I'm going to assume
that what they said is accurate. You suggested Steven pay for
Pixie's law school." Straight says, "But yes, this was one of
the few suggestions. I said that she's in a precarious financial
situation, that she's not consulted her, and that therapy bills
or payment to assist with law school would be money that would
be productive to her because it's something to look forward to."
All of these assumptions. I got it. I got it. We'll get Okay,
we'll come back to it. Okay. Uh, the something to look forward
to. Uh, she refuses to tell her family and things were breaking
down with loner and I felt overwhelmed being one of I don't know
how many people she's let into a limited support network. Now,
get get ready. I'm about I I hope I don't have to yell here.
This is one of the worst parts of this stream. So, let's hear
it again and let's hear her brain analysis and then I'll explain
what just happened. I got it. We'll get Okay, we'll come back
to it. Okay. Uh, the something to look forward to. Uh, she refuses
to tell her family and things were breaking down with loner and
I felt overwhelmed being one of I don't know how many people
she's let into a limited support network. Now, this one was edited.
I don't know what it said originally, but I think that it is
very I find this to be very
uncomfortable, disqu
I felt overwhelmed because I was a part of her limited support
network. Like, if you don't, this is your friend. If you cannot
support your friend, direct them to other resources. Okay. Um,
this I'm overwhelmed because I have to help my friend who's how
dare you. What the is wrong with you? I go she's dealing with
a friend or had her nudes
She's feeling overwhelmed and she can't have that feeling. That's
a that's a bad that's that's a uncomfortable. That's a whatever
she said with the disgusted face on look on your face. It is
well within the realm of possibility
that she felt overwhelmed
as she's confiding in her friend. She didn't tell Pixie, I'm
overwhelmed. She told president Sunday, "What is wrong with this?
What is wrong with this?" Now, Haiko, credit to her, she admitted
this was when I talked to her, or not in so many words, but she
admitted it's reasonable to feel overwhelmed, but this this is
just again going back to poor analysis,
bad analysis. Threats worried me because she kept saying it was
contingent on her parents finding out, not the general public.
Uh, but it was never pressing enough that I felt a wellness check
was in order. Luna reached out to me when he hadn't heard back
from her. I contacted her room and asked to please contact me
and then I think the day she responded to me and I made huh contacted
her room and asked her to please contact me and then I think
that day she responded to me and I made the suggestion to Steven
to offer compensation because it's what she wanted most. Is that
what she wanted most? Is that or did she did Pixie say that what
she wanted most was for Steven to have to uh deal with consequences
to impress upon him that this is not an okay thing to do and
make him less likely to do it in the future. Okay. So Aiko doesn't
have the DMs between Pixie and Straight and when they were on
screen she didn't even read them. So, I'm going to call her
uh I'm not going to call her anything. I'm just going to say
she doesn't care about the truth
because you don't know that who who brought up the compens if
Pixie did or did not bring up the compensation in their conversation.
From everything I've watched from Ieko and even when I asked
Aeko, she admitted she has nothing that proves that it was strictly
Aaron's idea.
Right. And let's hear that again.
Just to be clear, I made the suggestion to Steven to offer compensation
because it's what she wanted most. Is that what she wanted most?
It is reasonable conclude that Pixie would have told her what
she wanted most. You don't know that. You don't know that didn't
happen. You're just assuming. You're assuming that conversation
never happened. So, you're just calling a liar without evidence,
which is fine, but you don't have good reasoning here. Moreover,
it is well within the realm of possibility that it you could
even conclude. She doesn't even have to say it directly. She
wants things private, but she wants him to pay. She wants things
private, but she wants him to pay. She wants Destiny to pay the
consequences,
but she doesn't want to be in the newspaper and and her parents
finding out. That is her. She doesn't want to be embarrassed
about this further.
So what would retain cuz what remember she's going to do what
if her parents find out? Yes, she's going to kill herself. So
that's probably really important to her. Now in Iiko's brain,
she's thinking, "God, Straight is such an evil actor just trying
to save Destiny here. Just trying to save him from public humiliation
when both parties want this to be private as possible." Pixie
is very clear about her wishes to keep this private.
You're just assuming that she's doing this to help Desing when
there's no way we can conclude that Pixie was very clear about
privacy being important and she is best friends with Pixie and
she's advocating for Pixie here. And just to just to be clear,
there is a world in a world we might even live in where Straight
Raid is looking out for Destiny's best interest and that's all
she cares about. But there's no evidence of that yet. So there
may be DMs between Pixie and Shreade where Pixie says, "I never
wanted money. I don't want compensation and I don't care about
privacy." We don't have those DMs though. So the conclusion made
on the publicly available evidence is Ieko is wrong. There are
other possibilities and your conclusion is faulty.
Is that or did she did Pixie say that what she wanted most was
for Steven to have to uh deal with consequences to impress upon
him that this is not an okay thing to do and make him less likely
to do in the future? Okay. Yes. Yes, she wants him to pay. She
She said she wanted a amount of money from him that would be
enough where if she he thought about nudes
and distributing nudes, she would have to think of him that would
could involve money in private. That could involve money in private.
Um, Sunday says, "Do you understand that this is being seen as
you assisting in blackmailing someone?" Cuz remember, Sunday
wasn't the only one that saw it. Pixie Pixie asking for money
as that. Nick did. Nick is Nick. Sunday asked what that sounds
like to him. Nick said that sounds like blackmail. So, I would
also like to point out this is yet another example of how do
you have all this audacity to think that you know anything about
um how to handle a person constructing this reasoning uh assist
with law school with money that would be productive to her cuz
it's something to look forward to. You cannot be like here look
you have your whole life ahead of you. Yes, they do. But do they
feel it? No. Someone who is how do you have the audacity to help
your friend? How dare you straight help your friend?
You don't know anything about
and guess what I'm going to give you my opinion but I'm not going
to cite anything. I'm not going to site any credentials. This
none of this makes sense. Now briefly I'm going to pause to check
chat.
There are any questions so far? This is going to be very brief
and I think there's a latency delay. So if there are questions
thoughts I will take them and field them for I don't know a very
short period of time. Play a little bit of music while it goes.
Oh, what do we want to hear?
Sure. Aiko is not going to review this. Well, well, well. I guess
I can remove
the one the um
Wow. Aiko really has integrity here.
She said she was going to review this multiple times and she's
going back on her word. She does not want to review this. This
is just even though every time I came on stream she had to concede
multiple points. But this is all but she's not going to review
it. But she's going to review it but she's not. Wow.
Got to love a little bit of integrity. Okay, so it was a threat.
Actually, I needed to pick up her calls or she wouldn't review
it. Lovely. I don't have my ringer on. Sorry. Let's just pull
this up on stream, guys. This is great. I'm going to show why
I
has no integrity. IEO has no integrity. But this shouldn't be
news.
She She has some, but not when she's wrong. Let's take a look,
guys.
Let's take a look at Iiko's integrity.
I just tried calling her. I don't have my ringer on. So, why
does Io have no integrity?
IO has no integrity.
This is uh this good stuff, guys. Good stuff. Pick up now or
I'm leaving and not talking to you after stream tomorrow. Okay,
bye. I'm not even going to review this. This is
really really I'm not reviewing this because you won't pick up
my call on demand.
Isn't that wonderful, guys?
Isn't that wonderful? So, I can't stream without having my DMs
up, which was a choice. I just don't want to get distracted.
I I have a number of mis calls from her. Well,
I I guess I screenshot already showed up.
Good.
Plenty of mis calls. She's happy to talk about it. She definitely
disagrees, right? But I have to pick up within a certain time
or I she doesn't have integrity and doesn't stick to her words.
Isn't that interesting? I don't owe you to pick you up, pick
up your call within a certain minute period like some petulent
child
or you don't have integrity where you don't stick to your word
that you're not going to review that you're going to review this.
You said you were going to review this and I said I would talk
to you and stream but I didn't have my ringer on. I want a laptop
and I'm trying to I just don't like distractions. This is really
it. I don't like distractions when I'm doing something like this
where I'm laying out multiple points. I don't want the TTS showing
up with Kyla's stupid face, right? I just want to talk about
the things and if I you have to wait 10 minutes to have a conversation
with me, you should still have integrity. She's throwing a fit.
But that's okay. We're here for it. I don't hate Io, but this
is a bad move for them. This kind of shows she doesn't have a
lot to say. She wanted to talk in that time or she is going to
what punish me for not sticking to her word. I mean, I she's
always had me on to talk. So, I don't want to like I don't want
to say that she doesn't have integrity generally, but during
those calls, she seemed to lie to me. And I just got caught up
caught cut off when my first streams uh quit. She lied. She lied
to me on our call together. She lied to me. And at the time,
I thought she was just a stoner. But she seems to always lie
about her memories when it benefits her in that situation. When
she was wrong, when I proved that she was wrong, she claimed
she didn't say things. She said, you know, Riyle, I almost said
my first name. Riyle, you did, you know, I didn't say that. You're
misharing things. And I trusted her to be fair. I gave her that
trust and I said, I won't, you know, I'm going to look back.
And I didn't even look back at the stream at the time. I trusted
her. But then cuz I thought this was just a one day thing and
whatever. I proved a couple points I felt right on my end. But
then last night, she went on JTO stream and rewent through the
narrative with some points that I thought were wrong. But she
went back on what she said or what I I proved to be uh wrong.
She did not no longer agreed. She agreed with me while I was
on stream confronting her, then went on in future streams to
say other things that contradicted those statements.
So, she's not retaining information
that proves some of her narrative wrong.
And she was lying to me. She was being a lying sack of she was
lying. She said to me, I didn't say that, you know, Aaron was
doing anything maliciously and then in the stream she says it.
The conclusion was if she is a string puller, if Aaron is not
looking out for her friend and looking out for Destiny, she is
doing a bad thing. She is not helping her friend.
And you said you didn't say this, but you did. And now I called
you back. I've ranted here for a minute to see if you would call
me. And you didn't
you're lacking integrity on this. I proved you wrong and now
you're a sad sack. I'm not going to review this.
Rip. Rip. All right. Do you know do you know it's Do you think
All right. So, we have we have a genius in chat. Almighty Pork
Chop. Now, Riyle is just attacking Aiko's character. Let me ask
you, Pork Chop,
do you think liars don't lack a bit of character? Congratulations.
Okay, she's calling in. Fair enough. Hi, Eeko. Hey, so
so you um were slandering me
when you you took what I said context. Okay. You said you were
you said you were going to review this, right? And mine not picking
up the phone. Mine not picking up the phone does not change your
word. I didn't say I would take your call at every moment of
my stream or you know you know you don't review this on stream.
Okay. Okay. So, the um what I uh what ped me off is what I said
uh with Sunday. I said I wouldn't put his wet face on my on my
thumbnail.
I wouldn't make him wet out of respect for our friendship. But
I have time and again challenged Sunday. I even um he did something
I disagreed with to the degree uh the way that he talked to sick.
I didn't talk to him for months. I burned the bridge with him
because of that. Okay. You said conversation with something about
how I don't have integrity. Okay. I would do all the same things,
but I'm not
done face and make it wet.
Yeah. You also said you wouldn't cover anything, you know, his
bad actions unless he did a That's not true at at all. I said
I wouldn't put him on a wet thumbnail unless he I have covered
him. I have talked to him and I have thoroughly talked about
my disagreements with him. And when I was at him, I also talked
about that too. I actually fought on him, fought with him on
stream. So this this is what's going to happen because unfortunately
I've given you the trust and you've lied to me. So
I can't trust this statement.
I'm not going to I'm not going to reexain my stream. I lied to
you. Do I about what you said to me on the original straight
raid stream when we talked, I gave you the assumption that you
did not attribute any sort of uh ill intent or malice to straight
raid. And in the stream you did about straight raid. You said
I was misremembering or I didn't hear what I was stating that
I heard and then I went back and listened and you said those
exact things. You said I feel that straight raid is a string
puller. That she is not doing what's best for Pixie. Not you
don't say it like it was a whoopsie or a mistake. You said she
is pulling the strings here and to to hurt Pixie or to not look
out for her. She was pulling the strings. That is literally what
happened. But I don't care what's in her heart. Okay. I read
it more maliciously
before I talked to you and then you told me how maybe she was
just and I was like, "Okay, I could see that." Wait, so you're
admitting that you felt she was malicious? Which is what you
just said? I felt like Well, hold on, hold on, hold on. I thought
malicious means like you want to do evil to someone that you
have ill intent. Knowingly bad. Yes. Knowingly bad. That's I
don't think she was trying to over Pixie. I think that she didn't
have Pixie's best interest, but she had the uh the what she thought
was best for the overall situation.
And as you said, she thought that Destiny was her friend. She
thought that whatever these things, she didn't realize he was
evil. Okay. And when you when you put it that way, I was like,
"Okay, I'll make more room for her just being, you know, uh dumb."
But that doesn't change that. You said, "I didn't hear those
things." What? In our original call we had at the end of your
straight raid stream, you said I said to you, "Here, you were
you were attributed malice here and here's the thing." And you
said, "No, I didn't say that at all." And I said, "Well, I heard
you say X, Y, and Z." And I didn't have an exact quote. I said,
"I heard you say X, Y, and Z." And then you said, "I never said
those things." And I said, "Okay, I'm going to go listen. Did
I say that she is doing this maliciously?
Did I say those words? It's the spirit of the idea.
That means nothing to me. I will say things about people. I Okay.
Um, that's all that I wanted to say, I guess. So,
um,
can I get your word that you will review this and prove me wrong?
Fine. only because I said that I would. Okay, I will then I will
take back. I will take back. I thought, you know, cuz you said
in chat you were not going to review it anymore. If I can get
your word on that, I will apologize. That's fair. I'm also a
little heated here. I apologize. You have always had me on to
talk and you said you were going to review it and I have your
word here. I will I IO has integrity. I thought you you know
because you didn't answer my call and you did. We called. You
confronted me. you have integrity because you were willing to
see out some and you admitted on that call that there were some
things that we disagreed on that you saw my side on and I see
your side on as well. So I apologize. I was uh act I was speaking
out of turn when I said you lack integrity. Fair. Okay. I accept
that. Thank you. All right. Um I'll I will I'll watch the rest
of it when I review. Um and uh have a good have a good stream.
Bye. You too. Bye.
All right, guys. Look at that. Look at us building bridges as
it were.
All right. So, are we ready to continue?
This I don't know why she thinks that she knows how to handle
this, how things should operate. Okay. Like uh the threat's worrying
her, but it was never pressing enough that I felt wellness check
was in order. It was pressing. It was absolutely pressing and
all of you are just lucky that she didn't herself. Um I wouldn't
be surprised if Trader is autistic. She's kind of coded. It doesn't
matter because it's absolutely uh autism and empathy are not
uh mutually exclusive at all. somebody who lacks social cues
can sometime, you know, can display a lack of empathy. This is
just I don't know. I mean, I guess we'll Google it. I'm not an
expert and God knows. Um I go unfortunately is not a mental health
expert. Um
but um I'll try to tone down some of the like more hateful language,
right? She did say she would review it and she confronted me.
So fair to Io but autism
what uh show um do autistic people
lack empathy? Okay, so this is kind of what I thought. So autistic
people do not lack empathy.
However, they express empathy differently. For example, they
may struggle with interpreting social cues and expressing their
emotions verbally and understanding the nuances. So when you
are reading
straight and her lack of empathy here, you don't know what she
feels. You are stating what you can't know. You are stating her
internal feeling that she lacks empathy.
Now the word Aiko is looking for is sympathy. She is being unsympathetic
to Pixie here because she doesn't know her internal thoughts.
And somebody can easily show a lack of sympathy
when they misunderstand. It says here, right, that they have
the internal feelings,
but they don't express them the way other people do. So your
read on her lack of empathy is really you're reading her
And that is one in one in line with somebody who may not express
things the way other people do. Also, we have to reload the page
because we're in a different browser. You know, like it's a very
clear it's not about picking up on social cues. It's a direct
like it's a lack of empathy here. Okay. This I'm overwhelmed.
I can't believe she's doing that. It's stupid that she's doing.
You know what I mean? It's not about like what?
So again, we've made this point before, but when you're confiding
in a friend about your friend, stating one time that in the past
you felt overwhelmed, she's not even saying she feels overwhelmed
now. She's saying at this point in time, she's telling a recol.
She's not even looking for sympathy in the conversation.
Really, she's just explaining how she felt at the time. And if
your friend wants to kill themselves, your best friend, that
may make you feel a little bit overwhelmed if you're not a psychopath.
What kind of support does she need? If you don't care, you don't
want to support her. Fair to She agreed with me on this on my
first stream with uh first call with her. So, it's not like a
a big point that she didn't agree with. She agreed. No, it's
fine. Hey, Gamma.
Okay. Oh, these are the other this I started screenshotting from
uh Sunday's video. This we looked at. Oh, wait. No, we didn't.
This is when Pixie confronted Lab about lying quote unquote about
her sleeping with Destiny. You can read that on your own if you
want. uh time stamp straighter 8 says uh on the 16th if she did
that which I doubt that would be incredibly misleading. She wanted
she's wanted an incredible amount of money from the start and
I've repeatedly but gently told her she will not get the sum
she wants. There's no legal basis for her getting a million dollar
payout but she's repeatedly discussed with me. Um another thing
I will note why does trader think that she knows what's appropriate
or reasonable to ask for? That's for a lawyer to dec to talk.
The lawyer decided IO you just read the DM where she said she
spoke to a lawyer and the lawyer said it probably wasn't going
to happen. And she's just quoting the lawyer. She's quoting the
lawyer. She's quoting a lawyer and you're saying she should quote
a lawyer. Why are you call Okay, discuss.
What do you mean? There's no legal basis. I don't know what What
do you mean? Why are you trying to control this? Why are you
trying to like talk her into legal basis? She's strictly saying
the lawyer said there's no legal basis.
There's no control there. In fact, she again, she's not talking
to Pixie here. Again, when I say that she will not conf condemn
her friends, Pixie, she has a problem with Straight Red controlling
Pixie, which is what she thinks is happening, but she doesn't
have any evidence of that. But President Sunday gave direct orders
to Straight Red, you should say X. You should say Y. And we still
have not heard one time IO say, well, President Sunday shouldn't
be directing or ordering around a person. So, it's okay when
her friend does it, but it's not okay when straight does it.
That is my critique. that you are. I'm not saying you won't make
a thumbnail. I'm saying right here in the stream, President Sunday
did the thing you're condemning and you have no heat for President
Sunday and you said it was because he's your friend. You would
go easier on him or just do things differently. That is a problem.
You are compromised. Something just because you think it's in
her best everyone's destinies. Again, Aaron's the one that brought
up money in the first place. Okay, we already saw these. These
are just clearer versions of what we saw from the decade video.
Okay, so that was Sunday and Trader. All right, now we are going
to get into the worst part, which is I heard uh Trader's DMs
with Destiny. This is from his Pixie Manifesto.
Okay,
I just took some screenshots. Uh I took screenshots of the DMs
that he shared and some of the Google doc. So, I'll read a little
bit of this. Since threats of from Pixie were now involved, I
reached out to a mutual friend, Aaron. My understanding at the
time was that Aaron was an incredibly close friend of Pixie.
So, I sought her advice on what I could do to help. I spoke with
Aaron while the both of us tried to consult Pixie. Aw, how sweet.
Both of us. Aaron eventually suggested approving the exact message
even so she approved the message that he sent her that I read
earlier which was here. No, hold on. This this one.
So Shider approved this message. This feels super lame lame and
I don't at all want to imply that somehow just giving you money
helps anything go away or fixes everything for you. But if you
have any bills or owe money on anything or have any financial
stuff I can help with, I can at the very least chip in and help
with any of that. So it's at least one less thing you have to
worry about or stress over while you're worrying and getting
through this. So, this I think is interesting that he said and
Shredder can deny this if she wants unless he has a DM. I don't
remember. We'll see. I was like half awake when I was doing all
this. Hence how messy it is. I just want to note this. Sorry,
I'm doing something good. Brian, listening
also handling some things here. Approves the exact
send. Okay. Uh, proving the exact message even that I offer her
money to help cover at least her therapy or perhaps even payments
towards law school. After sending the message, Aaron approved
to Pixie, Pixie rejected it in what I thought was an odd manner.
She said that whatever amount she'd asked for would likely be
too high, despite me not yet mentioning a dollar amount. At this
point, I noticed her language was also taking a sharply pointed
and more deliberate tone with words like justice and non-conentual
and vulnerable showing up for the first time in our messages.
Almost 2 weeks out from when the original leaf actually happened.
I was trying to walk in and impossibly fine with my conversations
with Pixie, balancing a few key things I was worried for wellbeing
and mental health. I'm sure. I'm sure. Anyway, that's just a
portion. Okay, that's when the time stamp was 12:29 in his video.
Destiny addresses his lawsuit. That's where I got these from.
I should probably message Aaron approved to Pixie. Pixie rejected
it in what I thought was an odd manner. She said that whatever
amount she'd asked for would likely be too high, despite me not
yet mentioning a dollar amount. At this point, I noticed her
language was also taking a sharply pointed and more deliberate
tone with words like justice and non-conensual and vulnerable
showing up for the first time in our messages, almost two weeks
out from when the original leaf actually happened. I was trying
to walk in and impossibly fine with my conversations with Pixie,
balancing a few key things. I was worried for her wellbeing and
mental health. I'm sure. I'm sure. Anyway, that's just a portion.
Okay, that's when the time stamp was 1229 in his video. Destiny
addresses his lawsuit. That's where I got these from. Okay, now
hold on. This is very small. I need to make it bigger. Actually,
you know what? I'll read it off on my phone. I don't know why
I can't. I can't zoom into this anymore. Oh, wait. Can I? Oh,
never mind. I can. Just kidding. Okay.
Um, Destiny. So, this is again December 12th. Okay. Less than
two weeks after the leaks. Destiny says, "Okay, yeah, I have
no clue what to say or do." Trader says, "How much did she tell
you?" Destiny shares uh the DMs that Trader ended up sending
to Sunday. These ones where Pixie uh says that she's going to
leave this earth and Destiny's like, "You have so much to live
for." Trader 8 says, "I'm surprised she told you to be honest.
She didn't respond to this or did she delete it?" No. If she
responded and deleted, I didn't see, but I'm pretty sure she
just didn't respond. Trader says, "She's not doing well and she
had made all the wrong moves in response to this. I told her
to do nothing and not reply to people. Why is she talking to
Destiny about this?" Destiny says, "I don't think she's done
anything too too bad, like just privating her stuff for a bit
was fine." People straight say, "People have sent me stuff that
she said to them in DMs. She's denying it in private and DMing
people to stop talking about it because it's not her." Destiny
says, "Oh, well, I mean, if it's helping her process stuff or
whatever, it's okay. Unless she's just blowing it up more or
making it worse or something." So,
it gets way uh worse in my opinion. But just to begin with, like
can you imagine if Trader 8 hadn't done it how much of Pixiey's
hand wouldn't have been played
like because of trader Destiny had all this information on Pixie
vulnerabilities. It's an important time to bring up this point.
It is very rare the profession I'm in or have been most of my
life can give me any sort of credentials. Was in sales for a
long time. So, I know just know very very little very little.
I'm not an expert. I just know very little about negotiations.
It's not it's not even a good credential.
didn't gain
any substantial substantial excuse me leverage
when straight raid
learned
or straight raid told him that that Pixie didn't have a lot of
money. Yes, he understood a little bit more about her vulnerabilities.
straight didn't see him as inherently evil at this point yet
because it was the narrative was it was a hacker and the details
weren't exactly clear and Pixie doesn't share a lot of what is
going on. So Straight Raid is trying to put put together the
pieces and one of the people she's talking to is her longtime
friend Destiny. Yes, in retrospect this was stupid. This doesn't
make what she did was malicious or even a bad like she assumed
if there's a hack and if that is what is the narrative going
around and she has no reason to think Destiny is Giga the devil
talking to him to help Pixie is within a realm of possibility
if you don't think he's evil and Mavelian that is a choice you
can make it make it a bad choice it was the best choice she had
she felt she had with the given circumstances to help Pixie get
some resolution because Pixie wasn't even talking to Destiny.
Pixie didn't even really want to do the lawsuit thing from or
or wasn't like her her um she wasn't told that she was going to
get compensation out of it. So, it didn't even look like a good
option and it still may not be a good option. She still may get
nothing out of it and nothing but grief because what why was
she going to herself? Because her parents might find out and
her parents know now, right? So,
we can reasonably surmise Straight Raid wasn't just giving Destiny
information to hurt Pixie. She was trying to facilitate a solution
because Destiny's already talking to Pixie. Yes, some of the
information Straight shared inadvertently hurt Pixie. The idea
that she had this knowledge at the time is what I'm contesting.
Not just that, but it also um caused engagement that Pixie wouldn't
have done otherwise, my opinion. Like it's like the more you
do, the more you say, the more the other party knows, the less
room to maneuver you have. So Aaron was taking that away from
Pixie for what reason? Yes, she didn't take that away. Remember
one thing, if this goes public, Destiny loses a million dollars
easily.
When this went public and her story went public, Destiny loses
a million dollars easily. So because of this,
the idea
that Pixie lost any sort of leverage in the negotiation, which
I forgot to mention this in when I cited my credentials, the
idea that Pixie lost leverage because if any of this information
is patently wrong. It is patently wrong. The leverage is if the
story goes public, Destiny loses a million dollars. If Pixie
has $1, if Pixie is in $20,000 in debt, that doesn't change the
negotiating leverage that if this goes public, Destiny loses
a million dollars. He doesn't lose less money when the public
uh story goes public, but Pixie has a bunch of debt. It does
not change her leverage. It does not change her leverage one
iota. This is just a fact. In a negotiation, the leverage of
between these two parties, the the Pixie and Stra and Destiny,
the leverage is held
within the information going public. That is the leverage that
that's the information. That's the thing that he wants.
that thing does not change based on Pixie's mental state or based
that yes inadvertently having the information that she is she
is sad and doesn't want this wants privacy is information he
uses against Pixie but Destiny was going to find that out anyway
Destiny was going to get that from the the substack
so all of this information right yes he is evil yes he's going
to use that against her p straight raid I can't I mean so the
ultra the narrative Aiko sent that straight raid knew that Destiny
was evil but was giving her information about Pixie anyway that
is even if Aiko doesn't say the words that he's being malicious
that Stray is being malicious that is a malicious action. If
you know Destiny's going to use information against Pixie and
you give it to Destiny you are being malicious. That is a thought
through act. That is an act where you know the consequences and
you are doing them not out of recklessness but because that is
going to hurt Pixie. That is malicious by definition. Okay. Uh
next um it continues
uh Trader says to Destiny, "She went into spicy chat and said
their comments make her want to kill herself a few days ago.
She had told me she would do it if her parents found out because
I suggested reaching out to family members I could be trusted
to give her emotional support, but she's not really talking to
people." Laura messaged me asking if I'd heard from her because
she hadn't been messaging. Destiny responds to her going into
spicy chat saying, "Ah, this is bad." Yeah. Trader says, "Then
I messaged her tonight and she and that's when she said she thinks
that's what she needs to do." Destiny. Yeah. Saying that she
needs to herself. Yeah. Okay. Destiny says, "Well, I feel stupid
going over there or just asking her to hang out for obvious reasons.
I don't really know what else I can do or if I'm even a person
you can offer support." The answer is no, you cannot. Straight
aid. I don't know how she views you when she told me I wondered
if I should tell you and ask for help, but if she sees you as
an abuser, then it seems like the ultimate betrayal to do that.
Interesting. Interesting. So instead, you decided to just
do this instead.
So cool. Good stuff. Um,
if if she sees you as an abuser, then seems like ultimately to
do that. Same with telling her family if she's explicitly said
she can't rely on them for support. Like, I'd rather have her
at me for life but alive, but I also don't know how to intervene.
She doesn't seem manic, but I have no training to really make.
Wow.
Right there,
we have the answer to all of Aiko's questions. Would you look
at that? Aiko just read the answer to her own questions. I would
rather have Pixie mad at me for life than dead. Do you know why
I think Straight A isn't talking about things
Because anything she says might hurt Pixie. Saying her how she
had the best intentions might harm Pixie's public image that
Pixie was doing things sill silly things in public.
It's very easy to conclude that. She says it right here. I would
rather have Pixie mad at me for life
by talking to people and trying to get help for her to make sure
she's alive.
This seems like the most reasonable narrative. There's a through
line between all of her actions and just trying to keep her friend
alive.
Excuse me.
Which I said was, you know, unreasonable to feel overwhelmed
by that judgment. True. Actually, yes. You don't have you have
nothing that makes you qualified to make any kind of judgments.
Um, but a wellness check seems like it'll do because you just
act normal to that you don't make have any you don't have any
qualifications. This is what I was looking for. You don't have
any qualifications to make the judgment on this person.
IEO doesn't follow up that statement with qualifications she
has, but she will contradict Straight Arid's actions as not helping
a person.
Io, I'm sure has some sort of life experience with this or whatever.
She feels she has knowledge on this, but she doesn't cite any
credentials or qualifications. This is dumb. Even if I is right
and you say, "Hey, this person isn't qualified." And then give
an opinion, you should follow that up with a credential or qualification.
Otherwise, even if you're right, you're dumb cuz you just called
yourself dumb or unqualified. Get them to go away and they wouldn't
commit her on just my word alone. I told her similar some I can't
talk, guys. I tried to talk too fast and it doesn't work. Okay.
I told her similar things that you told her and that she really
needs to go speak to her about this. She said she hasn't done
that. But if she's telling multiple people, then it seems more
like a cry for help and I would try to offer that. I remember
like 3 or four years ago, she already had a lot of issues with
ideation stuff and I can only imagine her catastroph catastrophizing
this like crazy in her mind. But it's obviously in my interest
to go tell her to ignore it all and let it recede. So it feels
stupid to even approach her with that.
Yeah, in my interest. Yes. Um it might be worth going back to
Destiny manifesto and show him discrediting Pixie ideation based
on this from Trader. Trader was giving material for the Destiny
response. Buy what you can. Um, straight raid responds to uh
the
uh 3 four years ago ideation stuff. She says, "Yeah, but it's
also what she needs to do to move forward, even if you have competing
interests."
Destiny says, "I have no clue what I can rectify. I hired a private
investigator to try and find out the actual identity of the girl,
and I'm talking to another law firm tomorrow, but all the internet
is so obnoxious for anyone you care about. I'm like 20% worried
also that pushing big litigation against farms for this. This
would also cause all of it to blow up." More for her as well,
Trader says. And this is pure speculation, but I wonder if she
was seeing if you'd even reply or you go silent. Awesome. Um,
okay. Now, now it gets into it. All right.
Destiny says same same day. Yeah, maybe not. I don't know what
else to do. And then straighter says, "Money, dollar sign, dollar
sign, dollar sign, dollar sign. Offer to cover her therapy or
some I don't know her employment situation, but I don't think
it's good." Destiny says, "You really think so? I have zero problem
with that. I thought about it, but it feels super ultra scummy
or like I'm just trying to buy her off feeling bad or something,
but obviously 1 million% I would absolutely do this." Um, Shredder
says, "Yes, I really think so." LOL. She mentioned pursuing a
case against you in the that first screenshot you sent me. And
this isn't a crime that is punishable with jail as far as I know.
So unless she thought it did or some other punitive measures
she felt would deter you, I'm going to assume she was consider
doing it for financial damages. Oh, you're going to assume, huh?
So not only is straight a suggesting the money that that Destiny
pays for her therapy and potentially a budget law school, she's
saying that she thinks that Pixie was going to go after him for
money. So that's great. That's very helpful. Wonderful. Great.
This doesn't change anything. And then so uh responding to Destiny
saying, "What do you think would be the appropriate way of even
approaching her about that?" Shredder says, "Being honest and
frontloading it would genuinely not being able to rectify it
neutally because of the obvious conflict of interest, but you'd
like to try and that it's something you do if it would help her."
Therapy cost for sure. If you're feeling if you're really feeling
generous, something to do with her law school pursuits, like
year one or something. I don't know how far you're willing to
help, but I see it as offering her something to look forward
to in her immediate future, which again, I will say it's stupid.
It's ridiculous. And she is uh no not knowing anything.
Okay. Who the are you? I go, "Who the are you? I'm just a layman.
I don't know [__] about
that sounds like a reasonable
A better brighter future." Isn't that the reason people themselves
because they don't feel they have uh their life isn't worth living
currently? But if you have some reason to live, that probably
just sports
dissuade someone from themselves.
I hasn't cited any sort of knowledge even. And she hasn't even
said, "Oh, I I had a friend who blew her brains out." No, she
doesn't give any qualifications,
but somehow she's giving an opinion about straight a things here,
whatever she's she's suggesting to Destiny. How is this an issue?
She I don't I don't see so Pixie right now doesn't even have
the option of getting a payment from Destiny because
Pixie didn't reach out to to Destiny for for uh any sort of negotiations
or whatever. She got reached out to by Kyla. Kylo shut her down.
So right now Pixie has no options. Straight raid is trying to
give her another option that she can choose from. You're not
making Straight Raid didn't make the choice for Pixie.
She's giving Pixie another option. She's giving Pixie another
option, which is payment. She can still turn it down and go public.
Nothing prevents her from continuing, and nothing
loses her any sort of leverage in the negotiations. This is false.
This is wrong. If the story goes public, Destiny loses a million
dollars. Doesn't matter that Pixie's bank account is a
debt or whatever. If the story goes public, Destiny loses a million
dollars,
straight a can or uh Pixie can ask for a lot of money and just
because she's if Pixie was a let's just picture this. If Pixie
is a millionaire, she can still ask for Destiny for a lot of
money because he doesn't want the story to go public cuz he loses
a million dollars. If she has $147
and she asks him for some sort of payment, a large sum of money,
he can't go, "Well,
you only have $147."
Even that knowledge in his mind does not change her negotiating
position. She can still ask for a large sum of money. That does
not change. Oh, you're in debt. Great. I'll go public with the
story and you'll lose a million dollars. Wow. Leverage retained.
Setting up someone for a bright future is not going to make them
want to live it more. Again, these people are really lucky. She
didn't just kill herself. Um, it wouldn't have been because of
President
Wow, look at that. It wouldn't have been because of President
Sunday. Now, I'm not saying that she's wrong,
but it's interesting. There's no condemnation for his actions
when he made a brash decision. He did not care about Pixie's
wishes to at all to potentially go public with the story on her
own in her own control. Instead, he did a video where he called
her an extortionist, where he called her someone who blackmailed
Destiny.
This could easily have tipped someone over and felt overwhelmed.
This is silly. This is dumb. Says she's being compromised because
it's her friend. Um, okay. Uh, that is a goal she was working
towards in the midst of all this and would be a reminder that
her life isn't over because of this. Not even close. Destiny,
what law school was she looking to go to? Is money the only thing
stopping her from going or something? And even it gets better
and better.
Trader says, "I'm not sure, but she owes me $147 and is having
to pay it back to me in installments because she can't afford
the payment all at once, so I'm pretty sure there are hefty financial
constraints for her right now. I know she was studying for the
LSAT, but if she has a school in mind, she didn't mention it
to me. I assume it's something online or instate."
Destiny $147 question mark question mark question mark. Wow.
Cool. Yeah, because when I moved, we split the podcast equipment
and it was divided in such a way that she took more equipment
than I did.
When you shop in the Tom Thumb app, you can count on delivery
and as soon as All right, guys. I am uh quickly losing interest.
We're kind of belaboring the point now. I don't want to hold
you guys much longer. We're going to watch a little bit more
and then we'll probably uh conclude this thing and I'll take
a couple questions.
Destiny sends verbatim this what he sent to Pixie to Aaron for
her approval. Once again, I'll read it. This feels super lame
and I don't at all want to imply that somehow just giving you
money helps anything go away or fixes everything for you. But
if you have any bills or owe money on anything or have any financial
stuff I can help with, I can at the very le chip in and help
with any of that. So, it's at least one less thing you have to
worry about or stress over while you're worrying and getting
through this. Do you think this is okay? And Trader Aid says,
"Yes." Yes.
I think if it would only be Skevie to do this if you were like,
"Can I give you this money so you don't take legal action against
me, please? Thank you." Smiley face. Wow. So cool. Awesome.
Destiny, maybe. Yeah. Traitor says, "But you told her in the
first message she could still do that unless you meant to her,
but it reads like you're saying she could do that against you."
Destiny says, "I mean, me included." Yeah. Honestly, I think
I've made my point here. Uh, what are we two two and a half hours
in there? It gets redundant after here. Um, I I will take a couple
questions. Um, I think I've made my point uh pretty clearly.
Um, also I I can always go back and watch more if there's something
I missed on a future stream and Aiko is going to review it. So,
and if the audio is up, I'll reupload with better audio, but
I think it's fine. Uh, any questions in chat? Any critiques?
I will take all of your love and hate. What's my point that I
was wrong? Every thing she said is wrong. That's my point. Any
questions? The point is she's wrong. There there doesn't need
to be
I just did a uh you're comment chatter zoo. I appreciate you
being around. That is a dumb question. I just did a 2-hour stream.
I don't think you were here the whole time. If you were and didn't
get my point, I made it multiple times. I gave a summary. I gave
here is what I'm here for. I said why I did the stream and then
I gave like why I didn't do the stream immediately. And then
I gave a reason why I'm doing the stream now. Um, I'm I'm not
going to reiterate all that. I'm sorry. Okay, Pork Chop, you've
said multiple things. I mean, I I ran you through the mud earlier
and you didn't even respond. So, well, you know, your opinion
is less than nothing now. All right. I don't see any questions.
Um, okay. None of my feelings also poor job. None of my feelings
were addressed in when I gave an opinion. I would say fact A.
If fact A, then fact B. If fact B and fact A then fact C and
here's my conclusion and maybe afterwards I said and I
is not me stating my feelings on the matter and that all I stated
were my feelings. That is a rhetorical flourish a you know a
little bit of flagrancy to spice up the point. That's okay. Opening
your ears typically helps. How do you feel about taking some
of the aggro from straight rage? I don't if you want to clarify.
Um, the Trib asked a question. Let's see what you said. The trip
I did show up and Okay, I'm going back farther. I don't see your
direct question.
You want to restate it? I'll ask it and I'll stick around for
it. Um,
how do you feel about taking some of the aggro from Straering?
I I just don't I don't understand. Taking some of the aggro.
Is she a direct person? Yes, she is very direct. Doesn't make
her bad or even wrong. I ran from Aiko's calls. So, you're now
missing pieces of your memory because I took her call multiple
times on the string. Yes, my ringer is off to stay focused. If
that means I'm running if I call her back 10 minutes later, that's
not a me problem. That's a you problem. You don't have an accurate
look at the world. Oh, you think it's good? It's fair. I I just
I'm not here to run cover from straight raid. Straight raid seems
like a smart and nice person. I would not defend her if she did
something wrong here. I would call her straight raid Maxwell.
Everyone in chat who thinks I have some sort of bias or hate
Iiko, I would call her straight raid Maxwell. Iiko made a good
point here. She did not. All right, guys. Um, sorry, Trip. Couldn't
find your question. But, uh, you know, enjoy. Um, well, you can
think Aaron's dumb. She's I think she's a very smart person based
on her the way the way she talks about things and the way she
describes her thought process. Nothing shows that she's dumb.
Does that mean that if she did a bad thing, I wouldn't call her
a I would call her every name in the book. If she was if she
was straight Maxwell and she was just trying to over pixie, guess
what? I would call her straight Maxwell. I would call her evil.
But I have not seen anything to prove that. Io made an attempt
at proving that. And I feel she unfortunately fell in her face.
That is okay. Doesn't mean she's a bad person or even makes bad
analysis
a majority of the time. This was just bad. Guys, I think we're
good here. Um, enjoy the rest of your evening. Well, I'm See,
you don't understand this, Pork Chop. See, pork chop, I'm just
talking to you now. I ruined your dinner. That makes me happy.
Why are you telling me things that make me happy? I really love
it. I am so glad that I ruined your dinner cuz you're an idiot.
If somebody who is streaming and you stick around the whole time
to tell me stupid comments that don't make any sense and then
I say something that dragged you through the mud and then through
that I ruined your dinner, you're just posting your L's in chat.
Thank you very much. with that